if I could be in a movie and play Barry
Sanders that would be a dream come true
for me he's my absolute favorite I mean
we're built differently but I think I
could get
there Jaylen Ramsey he is off the Dome
just comes up with stuff right in the
moment I believe that Tyreek Hill for
the Miami uh Dolphins is unbelievable
and I think what he brings to his team
how he helps and uplifts that entire
team this might be the year where we
pick a wide receiver for MV
I do believe now that we could be
looking at a Philadelphia Miami Super
Bowl I think my Detroit Lions are going
to go to the NFC Championship Game and
at this particular moment in my life
that is enough for
[Music]
me